you've got to be differentiated and
unique you've got to know what your core
competency is and be great at it I think
what people fail to realize is that
there's there's got to be a defining
feature of your company and you've got
to be the best in the world of that
whatever industry you're in if you're if
you don't know more about it than
anybody else in the world whoever those
other people are they're no more gonna
kick your ass
got a job working for a company called
your business software and we were we
sold software and and I didn't know
anything about software I took one
computer class at Indiana and kind of
cheated to pass I figured you know
computers were new and technology was
new this technology was new so no way
had a head start on me because it was
changing so rapidly like it is today
that if I just put in the time I can
learn as much as anybody else and so I
taught myself I'd stay up late reading
software manuals taught myself different
little simple programming languages and
kept on getting bigger and bigger and
better and better but it was at a retail
store and one of my responsibilities was
to come in sweep the floor wipe down the
windows and open the store and I had a
customer who wanted me to come out there
and close the deal and it was a fifteen
thousand dollar deal fifteen hundred
dollar commission to me told my boss he
said no you need to be there to open the
store and I made the executive decision
that I was gonna go get the check
because you know I was living six guys
in a three-bedroom apartment sleeping on
the floor and this check meant I could
like not use the same holiday in towels
with holes in them that I'd stolen you
know but anyway so I went and picked up
the check thank you when I came back and
gave the check to my boss all would be
forgiven and you know the sales cures
all fired me fired me and so those
back-to-back experiences confirmed what
I already knew that that I was a
shitty-ass employee and then I better
start my
you just watched two amazing clips with
Mark Cuban take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]